Marisa Franco: Now,
as an expert on friendship,
I'm up against a lot
because of the hierarchy
that a lot of our cultures
place on love, right?
With familial love at the top,
with romantic love at the top,
and with platonic love,
friendship love, really at the bottom.
And with so many countries,
people feeling so lonely
and so disconnected,
I believe that if we leave friendship
at the bottom of this hierarchy,
it's like there's gold at our feet
that we're treating as concrete.
And so why are friendships so key?
Well, our bodies have always known
that we need an entire
community to feel whole.
And just being around
a spouse, for example,
only surfaces one side of ourselves.
So maybe the part of me
that likes to garden or do yoga
will begin to wither away
if my spouse, for example,
doesn't like these activities.
But then when I'm around a friend,
I can garden and plant
my pothos with them
or around another friend that I can
[do] downward facing dog with.
And I feel my entire identity,
accordion outward,
unfold and fan out.
And I experience the full richness
and complexities of who I am
when I have an entire community
to bring that out in me.
And so that's one of the reasons
why friendship is really important.
But I think there's two reasons
why we tend to really devalue it.
One reason is because we just
don't know how to make friends.
So luckily, I am going to help you
with that a little bit today.
But the other reason has to do
with something I like to call
the “paradox of people.”
That on the one hand we need people,
they make us feel healthy,
they make us feel connected,
they make us feel like
our very selves, right?
But on the other hand,
people are really scary.
They can dismiss us,
they can reject us,
they can actively harm us.
And so this sort of dilemma that we face,
the sort of entity
that we need the most
is also the entity
that can harm us the most.
And how we walk across this tightrope
handling this paradox of people
says a lot about our ability
to make and keep friends.
Because if we find ourselves
stuck in the place
where we see people as --
we mistrust people,
or we see people as potentially
rejecting us and harming us,
it's really hard to foster connection.
And this really materialized for me
one day when I had bought an apartment,
and I was really excited
to make friends with my neighbors
because I'm like,
"I'm going to be here for a while."
And I see a couple
of my neighbors in the hallway,
when I'm walking home
into my apartment with my ex at the time
who was living with me.
And I walk right past them, right?
Because paradox of people,
I'm scared of them,
they might reject me.
They might see me as weird
if I try to introduce myself.
So I scurry into my apartment
and my ex, he pushes me
back into the hallway
to talk to my neighbors
and says to me, you know,
"You're writing this book on friends.
What would you tell other people
who are in your situation?"
And so as I'm sort of stumbling
back into the hallway,
I'm thinking about a few things
that I have learned
through studying friendship so intensely.
And so two observations
that I have on friendship
and two takeaways for what we can do
to make and keep friends.
First observation,
friendship does not happen
organically in adulthood, right?
And in fact, one study found
that people that think
that it happens based on luck
are actually lonelier five years later,
whereas people that see it
as happening based on effort
are less lonely five years later.
So what does that tell me?
That if I was just there
hoping that my neighbors
would someday try to be my friends,
it probably wouldn't happen, right?
And so I would need to make that effort
in order to be able to make friends.
But second observation that I have,
based on reading
all the research on friendship,
is something called the “liking gap,”
which is a phenomenon wherein
when strangers interact and predict
how likely the other person
is to like them,
they underestimate how much
the other person likes them.
So this research really suggests
that we're less likely to be rejected
than we think.
Which leads me to my first
takeaway for making friends.
If you want to make friends,
you have to assume
that people like you, right?
The reason is,
when researchers told people,
“Hey, you’re going to go into this group,
and based on your personality profile,
we predict that you will be liked."
This was completely bogus, a total lie.
But they found that when people
went into this group of people,
they became warmer, open, more friendly,
because they made this assumption.
And so indeed, it became
this self-fulfilling prophecy
called the “acceptance prophecy”.
And when we assume we'll be liked,
we make it more likely
that we actually will be liked.
Whereas other research finds that people
that tend to assume that they're rejected,
even when the circumstance is ambiguous,
like, my friend, maybe they're just,
like, hungry or something,
rather than that they hate me, right?
Those people that go straight
to "maybe they don't like me,"
they actually become cold,
they actually become withdrawn
and they reject people.
And then they get rejected in return.
So I'm thinking of these things
in the hallway, you know,
right by my neighbors.
I'm thinking that, you know,
I can't wait for this
to happen organically.
OK, I'm afraid they're going to reject me,
but that's less likely to happen
than I actually think.
I should assume
that they're going to like me.
And then one last thing
I have to remind myself of
was to overcome something
called “covert avoidance,”
which is our tendency to show up
around other people physically,
but check out mentally, right?
Like, you’re hanging out
with people and you’re on your phone,
or that would look like me
just standing in the hallway
hoping that my neighbors talk to me.
And so to make friends, you have
to overcome covert avoidance
by not just showing up,
I showed up in that hallway, right,
but you also have to engage
with people when you get there.
So I ended up approaching
my neighbors and saying,
"Hi, I'm Marisa,
I just moved into 103,
It's really great to meet you."
And we start chatting.
And at some point,
you know, I asked them, like,
"Is there a group
where we can keep in touch?
I’d love to, you know, chat further.”
And they tell me about their cat group
that they have for cat parents
in the Drew.
And I don't have a cat, but like,
I'll take connection when I can find it.
So the cat group became
half cat group, half social group.
And I think sometimes we think
that you know, a tiny act,
something small like saying hello can have
colossal consequences for our life.
But when we can lean into the sort of
positive side of the paradox of people,
when we can initiate and assume
people like us, right,
it can have colossal consequences.
Because since I said that "hello,"
me and my neighbors,
we met up and we hung out every Friday,
socially distanced of the pandemic
in the garden behind our apartment, right?
And so I think that this experience
really taught me
the importance that while we all
face this paradox of people,
while we all face this dilemma,
that, if we want to make friends,
if we want to connect with people,
we have to be able to move away
from the part of ourselves
that is fearful, that is mistrustful,
that assumes people will harm or reject us
and turn towards the part of ourselves
that simply wants to love
and connect with people
and can ready ourselves to engage
in these new connections with optimism
and with hope.
You know, my niece
read my book "Platonic,"
and one thing that she took away from it
was that for friendship to happen,
someone has to be brave.
So be brave.
Thank you.
Whitney Pennington Rodgers:
Thank you, Marisa.
I loved all of that.
And I could see in the chat
that a lot of the members also really love
some of the things you shared there.
So thank you so much
for that wonderful talk
and for those tips which we will
dive into in this conversation.
And, you know, I think
just to sort of start,
your line of work is just so interesting.
Friendship is, it seems such
a unique area to research.
And I actually want to read something
back to you from your book
to help us understand a little bit more
about just the importance
of this type of relationship.
You say, “Friendship, in releasing
the relationship pressure valve,
infuses us with joy
like no other relationship.
Without needing to plan for retirement,
fulfill each other's sexual needs
and work out who should be
scrubbing the shower grime,
we are free to make
friendship territories of pleasure."
So can you talk
a little bit more about this
and just why friendship holds
such an important role
in all of our lives?
MF: Yeah, yeah.
Well, first of all, I'll take a step back
and say, like, clearly,
connection is so central to all of us.
You know, the research finds
that, for example,
loneliness is more toxic for your body
than having a poor diet or not exercising.
And these are things that we talk
about in the public health conscious,
but we don't talk about social
connection enough.
Maybe for our UK folks, you all have
a prime minister of loneliness.
So it's a little bit different, right?
But when we talk
about the impact of loneliness,
there's actually three different
dimensions of loneliness.
There is intimate loneliness,
which is the desire for someone
to be very intimate with.
There's also relational loneliness,
which is the desire for someone that feels
as close to us as a friend might.
And then there's collective loneliness,
which means I desire to be part of a group
working towards a common goal.
And this research on loneliness really
suggests that, just like I said,
we really do need an entire
community to feel whole.
Because if we just focus on being
very nuclear, you know,
just having a spouse
and that being the center
of all of our connections, right,
that’s maybe touching
on our intimate loneliness,
but not our relational,
not our collective, right?
And so I think a lot of us
found this in the pandemic that,
we may have been home with the spouse
or partner that we really loved a lot,
but we still ended up feeling lonely.
And that's because as social species,
as social creatures,
like, we just need an entire
community to fulfill us.
WPR: You touched on this
a little bit in the talk,
and in the book, you separate, sort of,
the way you think about friendship
to two categories.
You talk about, you know,
sort of a backward look
at how we've traditionally
experienced friendship,
and then you look forward at how
we could build better relationships,
better platonic relationships.
And so if we could just talk a little bit
about sort of that first section,
just diving into how we as a culture
tend to think about friendship
and how does this really impact
the way that we actually approach it?
MF: Yeah, so I'm reading
all the research on friendship,
and what sort of materializes
before my eyes
is that our personalities
are fundamentally a reflection
of our experiences of connection
or disconnection, right?
Like, in some ways our personalities
are coping mechanisms
from the experiences of connection
or disconnection we've received.
So whether you are friendly, open, warm,
vulnerable, trusting, cynical,
aggressive, even violent,
all of this is predicted
by what your history of connection
or lack thereof looks like.
So how we've connected
really affects who we are.
But not only that,
who we are really affects
how we connect, right?
Those people that have that history
of healthy relationships,
they have an internal set
of beliefs within them
that allows them to continue
to facilitate healthy relationships.
This is, if people are familiar
with “attachment theory,”
securely attached people,
who think others can be trusted,
who think they can be vulnerable,
who think they can turn to people
for support, right?
And they go into new relationships
with this set of beliefs
that allows them to continue to create
these new relationships.
Whereas people who have had difficult
previous relationships,
those can be internalized
as a belief system
that then can impede their ability
to foster further connections, right?
Because they may think
"people are going to reject me,"
that "I can't be vulnerable,"
that "I can never
feel safe around anybody,"
even when someone is safe,
they're still holding that assumption
and that judgment, right?
And so what I want "Platonic" to do,
because I know some people
hear this and they're like,
"Good for those people with healthy
childhoods, you know, whatever.
For me, I guess I'm doomed."
Absolutely not.
WPR: Your work is focused
specifically on adult friendships,
which, for a lot of the reasons
you've already outlined,
seem like are just really
challenging for us to develop.
But I guess, can you talk about
sort of, why this breakdown happens
and really when we start to see
that it becomes more difficult
for people to make friends in the same way
as you did when you were kids?
MF: Yeah.
So when I say friendship
doesn't happen organically in adulthood,
I don't mean that friendship doesn't
happen organically in childhood,
because for children it often does.
And they have certain ingredients
in their environment
that really foster friendship.
So Rebecca G. Adams, she's a sociologist,
and she says, you know,
for friendship to be fostered organically,
you need to have this repeated
unplanned interaction
and the shared vulnerability, right?
And so in school we have that.
We have that through our lunch period.
We have that through our gym,
we have that through our recess, right,
we're seeing people every day,
we're letting our guard down,
we end up sort of just
developing these friendships.
But when you think about adults
going into the working worlds,
you may have repeated unplanned
interaction with your colleagues,
less so now that we're doing more hybrid
and remote workplace, right?
But we're often not as vulnerable
in the workplace.
And that's why one study, and again,
this is caveat, US context,
one study found that the more time
people spend together at work,
the less close that they feel.
And so we need to recognize
that as adults,
we don't have the same
infrastructure we had as kids.
So we can't rely on the same set
of assumptions that,
oh, this is just going to happen,
I don't have to try,
I don't have to initiate.
Because as I shared from that previous
research study, if we think that way,
for a lot of us, it won't happen.
WPR: And I think also just in thinking
about what friendship brings
to the table for you,
how it benefits you,
you have this phrase in your book
where you say, “Connecting to others
makes us ourselves.”
And it's about much more than just
the pleasure of connection there.
Can you explain a little bit about that?
MF: Yeah. So Harry Stack Sullivan,
he's a psychiatrist,
and he has this theory called
the “theory of chums,”
which is basically that our chums
or our friends earlier in life,
they provide us with the sort of
relationship template
that we take on into our future.
So it allows us to continue
to connect throughout life, right?
And there is some research that finds
that if we connect in childhood,
we have good friends in childhood,
we have higher self-esteem in adulthood,
we're more empathic in adulthood, right?
And so he kind of argues
that the therapy experience
is similar to the chumship experience,
in that with your friends,
you share things that you feel like
you should be ashamed of, right?
And when you are ashamed of something,
you're not integrating it
into your entire personality.
You're trying to push it away
and suppress it
and not make it who you are.
And the shame can really take over
your whole personality
because you're pushing away this part
of who you are that you think is shameful.
But then so much
of your personality is spent
focusing on making sure
nobody finds out this thing, right?
And so that's why shame can be
so encompassing and enveloping.
But what Stack Sullivan argues,
is that when kids share
this shame with their friends
and their friends are like,
you know, we still love you.
You know, this isn't
a big deal for us, right?
And we still think you're amazing
and we accept that about you, right?
We begin to be able
to accept it in ourselves
and to bring whatever we felt shame about,
to see it as just part
of our personalities
rather than antithetical
to the personality that we want to have.
And we are able to sort of relinquish
all of the energies
that we spend trying
to push this thing away.
And so in that way,
the experience of experiencing
that platonic love from our friends,
especially at that time
in childhood, teenagers,
where we're very high in shame,
we're like highest in shame
than throughout our
whole lifespan, right?
That our friends are there at that time
when we're so high in shame,
to help us integrate that and to help us
connect to all sides of ourselves
so that we sort of begin
to become who we fully are.
WPR: It's just so interesting how much
vulnerability and shame play into this.
And in a way, it seems
like on the one hand,
as you get more confident,
you start to lose some of the ability
to make new friends,
but also using that confidence,
leaning into it to actually make
the friends is what you need.
So it's fascinating.
Well, I want to dive into some
of the member questions we're receiving
because they're also really interesting.
So TED member Arnoldo, they ask,
"Married people often complain
about lack of time
to cultivate friendships
outside of the marital circle.
What insights have you gained
in your research
about the effects of outside friendships
in a couple's relationship?"
MF: Oh, I love this question.
(Laughs)
I think that having outside friendships
is necessary for having
a healthy marriage.
I do.
And this is where
I'm coming from with that.
The research basically finds
that if I make a friend,
I'm not only less depressed,
but my spouse is too.
It also finds that when you get
into conflict with your spouse,
it negatively impacts your release
of a stress hormone cortisol, right?
But if you have quality connection
outside of that marriage,
that doesn't happen.
Your cortisol release is normal, right?
Other research that finds
that, particularly for women
who tend to have more close
intimate relationships,
when they go through difficulties
within that partnership,
they are more resilient to it when they
have this outside support, right?
And so it's just like,
if I can access this other person
to center me during times
of stress in my marriage,
I can return to that marriage
in a centered and grounded way.
And that's a resource for me,
and it's a resource for my spouse.
Where we see that people
that only have that close
connection with their spouse,
they have high rates of what's called
concordance, which means that,
however your spouse feels
is kind of how you feel.
Their, sort of, energy
affects you a lot more
when they're the only person
that you're looking to for support.
And so what happens is like,
the natural ebbs and flows
that can happen in a marriage,
they’re so much more impacted,
and there's so much more devastated
during those times of ebbs
because they don't have that support
outside of the relationship.
So I think sometimes we see,
we think of like,
"Oh, are my friends a threat to my spouse?
My spouse is spending time
with their friends,
they're not spending time with me."
But if we understand more broadly
the importance of friendship
and how it makes every other
relationship in our life better,
we will see that there's actually synergy
between these relationships.
That my spouse having friends
outside of this relationship
is what makes them a better spouse for me.
WPR: So, so much of it has to do
with the way we just think
about the role friendships
play in our lives.
We have lots of questions
that are coming in
about, sort of, the steps
to actually making friends.
And I think before we get into some
of those specific questions,
I know you, in the talk, sort of shared --
you started with two tips,
this idea of first, assuming
that people like you
and then overcoming
what you call covert avoidance
or that urge to sort of mentally check out
when you're meeting someone new.
What are some of the other ways
that you recommend people try to use
tools that people use
to build new friendships?
MF: So I can walk through my own
experience of making a bunch of friends
and share this in a story.
I went to Mexico City alone
and was there for 10 days
and was like, OK, if I spend ten days here
and don't make any friends,
I'm going to be very lonely.
So how did I make friends
when I was there?
First I went to a coffee shop.
I heard another American there
and I knew, you know,
he's less likely to reject
me than I think.
I also knew the research
on transitioners, right?
People that are in times of transition
are most open to friendship.
So people that are traveling,
people that have just moved to the city,
people that have just started school,
people that have just retired, right?
Those are the people to try
to connect with versus, you know,
someone who's been here for a while
and already has an established network.
So I knew this guy's a transitioner
and he's less likely
to reject me than I think.
So I'm going to engage with him.
And I asked, you know, where are you from?
Like, I'm from the US too.
We start chatting and I end up inviting
him to a meetup that night,
and it’s like a language exchange meetup.
And at that language exchange meetup,
I meet someone else who's cool,
and I say, you know,
“Do you want to come to this Lucha
Libre wrestling match with me?”
Then he said, yes, and I think ...
You know what I realized, too,
from the research on friendship,
I used to think that making friends
was about being interesting, being smart,
being insightful, being charismatic,
being entertaining.
But in fact, people report
that this entertainment factor
is the least important quality
they look for in a friend.
And the most important quality
that they look for
is someone who makes them feel
like they matter.
So for me, if I want
to connect with someone,
it's not about me trying to impress them.
It's about me trying to make them
feel valued and, you know,
say hello to them and engage with them
and tell them what I like about them
and tell them what I appreciate
about them, right?
There’s this study
that looked at friendship,
budding friendship groups,
for like 12 weeks,
which of these pairs
ended up becoming friends.
And it was the ones that shared
the most affirmation
and affection towards each other, right?
And so, just to go even deeper
into the research rabbit hole,
there’s a theory called
“risk regulation theory,”
which indicates that we decide
how much to invest in a relationship
based on our view of how likely
we are to get rejected.
So when we show people
"I like you," we're telling them,
"Hey, you're not going to get rejected
if you try to be friends with me."
And that makes people really
feel safe connecting with us, right?
So I was both engaging with these people
and I was trying to make them feel loved
and tell them how great
I thought they were
and how happy I am to meet them
as I reached out to them.
And then I went to my Spanish class,
which, if you don't have any friends,
what I recommend is that you join
something that's repeated over time.
And remember,
I said repeated unplanned interaction
and shared vulnerability
is that infrastructure
that kids have for friends
that we lack as adults.
So as adults, we really need
to recreate that infrastructure.
And so if you join like, a social group
that's repeated over time,
turn your hobby into a community, right,
that's a really important
way to make friends.
So for me, it's I want
to take the Spanish class
because I love learning languages.
For you, it might be football team,
improv team, hiking team,
meditation group,
but it's just finding something,
finding a group that meets
around this hobby.
Because when you find something
that's repeated over time,
what happens is something called
the “mere exposure effect” sets in.
The mere exposure effect
describes our tendency to unconsciously,
completely unconsciously, like people
just because they are familiar to us.
So, for example, this researcher found
that when he planted women
into a large psychology lecture,
at the end of the semester,
none of the students remembered the woman,
but they reported liking the woman
who showed up to the most classes,
20 percent more than the woman
that didn't show up for any, right?
Nobody remembered her,
but they liked her a lot
because they had seen her face,
like this is our brain, right?
And what I think the other implication
of mere exposure effect is
in the beginning,
mere exposure hadn't set in.
So it's going to be awkward,
it's going to be weary.
You're going to feel uncomfortable, right?
Maybe a little distrusting.
That's not a sign that you need
to stop showing up.
That's a sign you need to keep showing up
because when you continue to show up,
they're going to like you more,
you're going to like them more, right?
So I joined that Spanish class,
that was repeated over time.
Every day in Spanish class, I would ask
people to go out to lunch with me.
We'd go out to lunch together,
then we went to Lucha Libre together.
You know, of course,
I was only there for 10 days,
so I can only go so deep with folks.
But in general, when you join
this event that's repeated over time,
you want to start generating exclusivity
with someone in that group.
Exclusivity means you develop memories
and you develop experiences
with one person in the group
that you don't have with other people.
So pick whoever in the group
that you really liked and ask them,
"Oh, would you be open to like,
getting coffee, getting tea
like, before or after our next group?"
Like, "I love to hang out"
and those are like, the budding
stems of friendship.
And luckily, if you're
in this group, right,
you don't have to put in as much effort,
you had your tea,
and now you're going to just continue
to see them over time,
and you have the wheel start moving
for friendship and connection.
WPR: So TED member Celia actually
is curious about virtual friendships
and sort of how all of this plays into it,
especially to some of the points
you were making earlier
about the pandemic.
You know, for people
who have met on social media only
as opposed to in real life, they ask,
"Is it possible to have a strong
virtual friendship?
How important is in-person connection
or getting together in real life?"
MF: Yeah, so this is such a nuanced
question in some ways, right?
Because it's such a "both/and."
We know from the research
that in-person connections tend to be
stronger than virtual connections, right?
But I think that that research,
it doesn't account for certain communities
like people with disabilities,
people with severe social anxiety,
even older people that aren't as mobile,
who tend to find connections online.
And even though, you know,
the online connections tend
to not be as deep as in person,
they can get deep
if you're practicing the same skills
that you can practice
in offline connection
to establish deeper relationships.
So, for example, like, the research finds
that if you're just passively scrolling
on social media, doomscrolling,
it makes you more lonely
and negatively impacts
your mental health and well-being.
But if you are engaging
actively on social media,
I'm posting,
I'm commenting on something
that you shared,
I'm saying congratulations to you,
that's actually linked to less loneliness
and is something that actually makes us
feel more satisfied in our relationships.
So if we want to have deep virtual
connections, it's certainly possible.
But we have to bring those same principles
that we use in offline connections
to create more intimacy,
things like being vulnerable with someone,
being generous with them
or showing affection towards them.
That also works online.
They feel like they like one another more.
But when you're vulnerable
with someone who's avoidantly attached,
that doesn't necessarily happen.
The avoidantly attached person
doesn't like you more
because you're vulnerable,
because they have their own
wounds around vulnerability, right?
They've learned that it's not good
to be vulnerable,
"I shouldn't be vulnerable."
Like, that's the implicit
message that they have
that really inhibits
their ability to connect.
So the implications of this, I think,
is that if you're vulnerable
and it doesn't go well
and it wasn't from a place of fear,
remember that it's not always your fault.
That other people have their own issues
that they're dealing with
which may lead them to respond
to your vulnerability negatively.
And that doesn't mean
that you did anything wrong.
I mean, I think if you continue to try
to be vulnerable with this person
who's shown you that they can't handle it,
then I think you should
try to pivot, right?
But just because someone responded
dismissively to your vulnerability,
it might mean that they have
their own issues to work out.
WPR: I think, in sort of thinking
about how to make friendships work well
or to be really good at this process
of doing this, you know,
there's a popular excerpt from your book
that you shared in "The Atlantic"
where you talked about the concept
of super friends.
So what makes someone a super friend,
and how can we all strive
to be super friends?
MF: Yeah, secure friends,
aka super friends.
These people are secure with themselves,
which means that they don't have
to try to use other people
as a tool to fulfill their sense of self
or to help them escape
threatening emotions or feelings.
So they're able to really humanize
other people fully.
And the research on securely
attached people find,
and again, these are the people
that have a history
of healthy relationships,
but there’s also earned-secure,
which means you may not have had
a history of healthy relationships,
but you've done the work on yourself
to develop a sense of security, right?
Remember, this isn't --
nobody's doomed by their attachment style.
But what qualities do we see in them?
They're more likely
to initiate friendships.
to maintain friendships.
They're less likely
to dissolve friendships.
They're more generous towards other people
because, again, they fully
humanize other people.
Insecurely attached people,
they sometimes perceive other people
through the lens
of their own wounds, right?
So anxiously attached people, it's like,
you need to prove to me
that you value me and you love me
because I'm so afraid
that you're going to abandon me,
and then I can try to control you
and make you do things
to show me that you really,
really love me, right?
And so they're not fully
humanizing another person
because they're almost
seeing that person as a tool
to fulfill their sense of self.
Avoidantly attached people,
they just think everybody's
out to harm them
and that everybody's untrustworthy.
So they almost see
other people as threats,
so they don't fully humanize
people for their beauty
and the resources that connecting
with another person can bring you.
But these securely attached people,
they tend to assume
other people like them.
I talked about something called pronoia,
which is the opposite of paranoia.
It's the idea that, you know,
the universe is commiserating
for your success and for your well-being
and that you can trust people.
They're comfortable with vulnerability,
they're more empathic,
they're comfortable sharing their needs,
but also fulfilling the needs
of other people.
They're more responsive
to the needs of other people.
When they engage in conflict,
it’s all about perspective-taking.
They're not like, "You do this,
otherwise I'm going to be pissed off."
They're like, "These are my needs.
What are your needs?
Let's figure out a way to collaborate
and figure out something
that will work for both of us.
So they tend to be quite healing friends.
They tend to be --
I talked about avoidant being
low effort, low reward.
Anxious is high effort, low reward.
Secure is high effort, high reward
when it comes to friendship.
WPR: And then what about friendships
where there's not necessarily
a difference in values,
but maybe a distance,
whether that's a physical
distance has been created
or some sort of emotional distance
because your life has changed in some way?
How do you suggest people
go about maintaining
and nurturing those types
of relationships?
MF: So there's research
on long-distance friends
that finds that we are helped
when we perceive our friendships
as flexible, not fragile.
So when we perceive that,
"Oh, I haven't talked
to this person in a few months,
I'm going to assume that friendship
is asleep, not that it's dead,
so that I can reconvene
this friendship at any time."
Right?
So it's being able to recognize
that our friendships ebb and flow.
And when we're at an ebb,
that doesn't mean,
"OK, I'm never going to contact
this person again,
because the friendship
is officially over."
We assume that this ebb is part
of the normal process to flow again.
So that facilitates us being able
to re-engage in the friendship
at any time.
So basically, this all goes back to,
I really think, this tip, right?
It's such an all encompassing tip, right?
Because what I'm basically telling you
is to assume people like you, right?
Like, if you don't talk
to your friend awhile,
assume that they're still interested
in being friends with you.
Again, this isn't about,
you know, being delusional.
If someone's clearly indicating
that they're not interested
in a friendship with you, then move on.
But if it's ambiguous and you're like,
"I'm not really sure,
we haven't talked for a while,
but they haven't necessarily rejected me
or they still are responsive
when I reach out to them,"
you want to make that
your running assumption
in response to ambiguity,
because again,
having that assumption
really facilitates continued connection.
[Want to support TED?]
[Become a TED Member!]
[Learn more at ted.com/membership]